la vente directe de l'agriculture au
consommateur est une pratique qui prend
un essor considérable ces dernières
années en cause une prise de conscience
croissante pour une alimentation plus
durable car quand un produit est
acheminée directement du producteur au
client cela permet d'économiser du temps
de l'emballage et des émissions dues au
transport et cette fameuse prise de
conscience et une source de revenus non
négligeable pour le secteur de
l'agriculture au bord du précipice en
france et en europe
les chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes en
moyenne les agriculteurs l'union
européenne ne reçoivent que 21 % de
l'argent payé par les consommateurs pour
leurs produits le reste est grignotée
par les intermédiaires soit en moyenne
28% pour les transformateurs et 51% pour
la grande distribution
une situation qui rend les producteurs
fortement dépendant des grandes chaînes
alimentaires vous l'aurez compris leurs
positions négociations est extrêmement
faible dans cette industrie
malheureusement passé aux circuits
courts n'est pas évident pour tout le
monde en 2015 la part des aliments
commercialisés en circuits courts ne
représentaient que 5 % de la valeur
totale des produits agricoles en europe
principaux obstacles manque d'argent de
personnel de capacités logistiques et de
publicité pour mettre en place un tel
concept
qui plus est il est difficile de mettre
en place un système de livraison
individuelles surtout pour les plus
petites exploitations
mais en france les chiffres sont plutôt
encourageants et de plus en plus
d'agriculteurs tente le coup la tendance
à augmenter de 19 à 21% dans les 30
dernières années
[Musique]